after days of calling for calm in
ukraine and downplaying u.s warnings of
an imminent invasion a change of tone
from president vladimir zelinsky in an
address to the nation
we are being threatened by a big war and
a date of military invasion has been
scheduled once again it is not for the
first time a war is being conducted
systematically against us on all fronts
on the military front the military
contingent has increased around our
borders on the diplomatic front they are
trying to deprive us of the right to
decide foreign policy on our own
it came after a visit by the german
chancellor to ukraine the latest western
leader on a diplomatic mission to
diffuse tensions with russia and avert a
new war in europe
after more than two hours of talks with
zelensky schultz promised keeve more
german financial aid and issued a
warning to moscow
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity are non-negotiable for germany
we therefore expect russia to take clear
steps to de-escalate the current
tensions
for germany it is clear that further
military aggression against ukraine
would have serious political economic
and geostrategic consequences for russia
solenski said ukraine must join nato
because the country's security was
inseparable from europe
as for our future alliances our
ambitions you know very well that this
is our wish but apart from that there is
a war in the east we believe that nato
membership will ensure our security
silence was forced to clarify ukraine's
position on nato after comments earlier
in the day made by ukraine's ambassador
to london that suggested that ukraine
could be flexible when it comes to its
ambitions to join the military alliance
comments the ambassador later retracted
we are not a member of nato right now
and to avoid war we are ready for many
concessions and that's what we are doing
in our conversations with russians but
it has nothing to do with nato which is
enshrined in constitution
moscow doesn't want ukraine in nato and
says that the west has ignored its
security demands but in a possible sign
of hope russia's foreign minister has
advised president vladimir putin to
continue with dialogue
our possibilities aren't exhausted of
course security talks can't continue
endlessly but at this stage i would
propose to continue and increase them
all right
a move that will be welcomed by schultz
who will meet the kremlin leader on
tuesday in what some say could be a last
chance for diplomacy natasha butler al
jazeera kiev